les travaux de recherche réalisés à bord
de ce laboratoire flottant le lem ces
listes sont d'une ampleur sans précédent
aux sédiments poisson tout est passé au
peigne fin par l'équipe de chercheurs et
d'étudiants
l'idée ici c'est qu'on fasse un cocktail
multi des sources de pollution des
nouvelles et des anciennes et on essaie
de trouver ça ensemble le point de rejet
de la station d'épuration des eaux usées
de montréal sur la pointe est de l'île
est un secteur névralgique luz et ne
rejette au fleuve
une véritable soupe de bactéries et de
produits pharmaceutiques par exemple une
tonne de molécules actives
d'antibiotiques sont relâchés chaque
année l'inquiétude c'est que en charge
en antibiotiques est significative et
qui contribue à développer la résistance
aux antibiotiques
la station d'épuration traite près de la
moitié de toutes les eaux usées du
québec
comme elles ne sont pas des infectés la
charge en bactérie e.coli racheter au
fleuve est colossal
ces bactéries sont présentes jusque dans
le sud des îles de sorel berthier on
peut encore les déceler au beau milieu
du lac saint-pierre et elles ne
disparaissent qu'à la hauteur de trois
rivières heureusement les îles de sorel
berthier et les chenaux semble filtrer
en bonne partie ces bactéries des
processus biochimiques et de
sédimentation 4 ou transforment la
matière organique donc hectares de
phares qui se passe dans les îles
on a noté pendant ses missions là la
question menace d'abord s'ils sont au
rsa bioréacteur là maintenant qu'est-ce
qui va commencer d'avoir ça marche
mais l'archipel a ses limites face à la
présence quasi généralisée de pesticides
dans le saint laurent
on voit que 80 % grosso modo chaussures
qui viennent du fleuve qu'on nous aurait
dans ce projet-là en moyenne 60 tonnes
d'atrazine et de ses dérivés sont
véhiculées par le fleuve en provenance
des terres agricoles
l'atrazine affecte les comportements et
les mécanismes de reproduction des
poissons et des amphibiens et les deux
tiers des échantillons d'eau ont des
traces de néonicotinoïdes des pesticides
qui s'attaque au système nerveux des
insectes pollinisateurs et c'est quelque
chose qui va agir sur les insectes
évoque un potentiel d'affecter des
invertébrés d'affecter où beaucoup de
petits animaux qui sont présentes dans
l'environnement dans une aquatique
le lien entre la pollution agricole et
le développement des cyanobactéries est
aussi connu ces algues microscopiques
prolifèrent dans le lac saint-pierre le
suivi de leur développement dans le
fleuve envoie un signal inquiétant
depuis 20 ans on observe une
augmentation systématique de la
production de cyanobactéries dans la
colonne d'eau central de kingston
jusqu'à trois-rivières et le cumul des
effluents de la métropole et de la
pollution agricole laisse entrevoir une
tendance à lui trophies à sion à la
dégradation du milieu aquatique
on n'est pas encore le niveau
astronomique être ce trafic de
tractations de saint orens mais les
données suggèrent comprend vauvert
pendant ce temps ci des pesticides sont
abandonnées aux bannis des pesticides de
remplacement apparaissent aussi sur le
marché et près d'une centaine de
municipalités au québec déverse toujours
leur ego directement dans le fleuve et
ses tributaires la ville de montréal a
prévu construire une usine d'ozonation
pour désinfecter ses eaux usées le
projet a été annoncé en 2008 mais les
travaux de construction de l'usiné n'ont
toujours pas débuté
rien pour rassurer les chercheurs
véritable gardien de l'environnement et
témoins des changements qui s'opèrent
dans ce long fleuve en apparence
tranquille
ici france beaudoin radio canada à
québec
[Musique]